i love learning about the behind the
scenes of the making of shows movies
things that like you don't read in the
press notes so for both of you what do
you think fan like soon to be fans of
the halo series would be surprised to
learn about the actual making of the
show oh my gosh at the making of this
yeah i mean how much fun we actually had
no that that's that's that should be
surprising how hard it was maybe yeah i
was gonna say like we kind of have a
joke well you know this is halo so
anything could happen because i feel
like any adversity that could get thrown
our way
did yeah and the end just the it was
such a huge production to begin with i
mean honestly it it was like making
multiple feature films and that's how we
approached it from a you know sort of
production value and
and um sort of scope and scale and
talent level of the crew
um
there was never never a simple day
because
if you're shooting a scene in a normal
television show set in the 21st century
you can say okay sit in that chair we'll
bring a glass in 26th century you're
like well what does a chair look like
what does a glass look like what are
they eating
have you established what this world
looks like okay what are they wearing i
mean just everything became
meetings and questions so everything you
see on the screen is a product of
thousands of hours of conversations
among different departments building
something and then making sure we're all
making the same show at the same time
which is what our job was and and you
know we don't show a lot of everyday
life in the video games
right so there was a lot of invention
from a from a visual design and
production design perspective but
i think really
it was an amazing experience because it
was so hard and i think when we all i
remember so well that last day of
shooting
you know
we were sort of all in the trenches
together and we came out of it feeling
triumphant because frankly we survived
um yeah we were standing in a pile of a
puddle of mud yeah and saying thanks for
three great years or two you know i mean
it's you've been filming for 10 years
let's begin exactly exactly you know
yeah in fact uh i was thinking to keep
you guys third of my life
this week for me is three years since i
started on the project and i'm still you
know in mixes and visual effects and
scoring and everything you know i have
to ask you because you've been greenlit
for a second season um for fans that are
gonna finish
when do you actually think you're gonna
start filming season two yeah i mean
we're the
what what we really don't want to do is
have
two years until the next season right
and we're also all very excited to get
in there and do all the things that that
you know we
um we learned from season one or didn't
get to do so
um you know i would say we're eager to
get back into production as soon as
possible and we're we're definitely on a
path towards production taking a video
game a movie animation each thing has to
be adapted for its own medium and i
personally uh have no problems with
master chief taking off his helmet i
think you need it to show pablo it needs
to be done on the series you know when
he's in a personal moment he's not going
to be sitting there with he's a human
he's going to take his helmet off but
could you sort of talk about um that you
did want to do that and why it was
important to you guys that you would
show the humanity of these of these
people yeah i'll start on it but steve
should speak to the moment because he
treated that moment in writing to it
with with such
respect and gravitas but
um
you know it wasn't something where from
the get-go we said his helmet needs to
come off you know we left it open
but it was also always a goal and a
priority that this was going to be about
chief's story and more importantly was
going to be about john's story because
john as a character isn't someone that
we explore in the games very much we do
in novels and
and so as we started getting into what
that what that evolution looked like and
what it meant for john to sort of
understand his role as master chief and
what that means and frankly his his role
as a human and in the broader question
of humanity at stake it was so clear
that we needed to be able to see the
person in the helmet and we needed to
see john outside of the armor both you
know i would say emotionally and and
physically and then you know when it
came to the writing of the moment it was
so important that
that that moment reflect
why it was important in this story right
because story's going to drive drive
everything and and i think that's an
area where steve really well i think you
said it great i mean that we didn't just
treat it like he gets on a ship throws
his helmet off and oh okay he's taking
off his helmet we made
essentially the season about taking off
the helmet so really we leaned into the
helmet removal as the sort of wellspring
from which the rest of the
season progressed um flowed um
the show really is about who is john
right and it's
you as a if you play the game you are
john you don't ever see his face
so now we're getting a chance to show
you no this is john and we're gonna have
john figure out who he is and you're
gonna go along for the ride
so the goal was to make the helmet
removal
a big enough moment for all of us so
that if you don't know the show you're
like okay this is obviously an important
moment but if you do know the game and
the lord you're thinking okay
our journey is going to begin and we're
going to take you along this journey
with john as he discovers his own
humanity so you're right there with john
sort of taking off the helmet with him
and discovering who he is together on
that no negative stop i'm just going to
say thank you again great congrats on
the yeah it's so fast and uh i can't
wait to watch the rest of the episodes
thank you
you